if you want to practice being
charismatic when we're getting to know
one another what do you do for a living
where are you from and people take these
questions and just submarine the
conversation you'll realize that the
question the person is asking you is
please tell me anything interesting
about yourself with which I can connect
and do the favor of sticking out some
velcro for them to attach onto so
instead of saying Philadelphia I might
say you know I grew up on the East Coast
but I was always a little bit of a crazy
person so in college I moved to Brazil
and did all this crazy entrepreneurial
stuff with a bunch of friends but now
I've realized that I much prefer summer
Sports and surfing and I live in
California within that there's all these
different directions that the person
that you're speaking to can listen to
and decide to hook into when you give
them five six seven options in a three
sentence answer you're going to
naturally go down conversations that
both people are more interested in
relatively easy principles to follow you
know that if somebody was to do this and
on a regular basis that they would be in
probably the top five percent of
communicators top five percent of funny
people that you know